fillon arrive il est 11 heures pile et
nous sommes en direct avec vous vous
êtes en direct pour suivre le décollage
de thomas pesquet vers la station
spatiale internationale iss
le retour de thomas pesquet dans
l'espace quatre ans après son premier
voyage vous l'aviez peut-être suivi déjà
en direct avec nous on ne vous étiez
plus d'un million allure avec nous en
2016 et 2017 son décollage sortie dans
l'espace et cette fois il y retourner
dès retourne sur space x tristan tristan
vais vous êtes journalistes comme si au
figaro spécialiste espace commence à
vatry sens très bien et toi mais ça va
bien on va vous voyez aujourd'hui très
heureusement on est entre gens sérieux
on descend le figaro on prend bien
évidemment vos questions et vos
commentaires dans le chat sur youtube
sur la page de une du site du figaro.fr
on va être ensemble pendant une heure
une heure et demie deux heures environ
le décollage aura lieu à 11h49 renan
laisse blaise est à la réalisation et
vous voyez derrière nous et en plein
écran les images de cette de cette fusée
falcon 9 qui est en préparation à cap
canaveral en floride une fusée falcon 9
tristan de space x c'est ça la vraie
grande nouveauté de ce lancement aussi
c'est pas seulement qu'il ya un français
thomas pesquet l'intérieur c'est que
c'est une fusée space x et ça c'est tout
nouveau
c'est seulement le deuxième vol habité
opérationnelle d'une fusée d'une fusée
spectacle qui reprend thomas pesquet le
troisième voie l'habiter parce qu'il y
avait un vol de démonstration le vol des
mots de avec deux américains à bord qui
avait passé quelques jours à bord de
l'iss avant de redescendre et le
deuxième vol opérationnel c'est-à-dire
qu'ils transportent vraiment un équipage
qui va rester à bord de bss pour une
mission complète c'est la première fois
qu'un européen vol avec space x à bord
de la capsule crew dragon donc c'est
thomas pesquié qui à cet honneur il ya
aussi un japonais
à bord il y avait un japonais déjà dans
la dans la mission précédente la mission
crew one donc assez la mission crew de
la capsule dragon c'est le c'est un peu
le futur c'est par rapport à la capsule
soyouz à la fois très fiable et très
rustique des russes bord de laquelle
thomas avaient pris place nous kaki à 5
ans maintenant enfin bientôt cinq ans
à baïkonour là c'est très différent donc
c'est ici que sont plus à tout un
décorum autour voilà l'arrivée des
astronautes en tesla blanche sur le pas
de tir le petit le pouvoir tu sens une
elle va le voir là d'ici les 40 minutes
qui nous séparent du décollage on
regarde ça et on va de prendre vos
questions et vos commentaires qui sont
déjà dans le tchat
tristan c'est pour ça qu'on a qu'on va
pas perdre de temps voilà run en
l'espèce de l'arrestation vous passe les
images tout à l'heure de l'arrivée des
astronautes alors bien évidemment dans
un véhicule tesla parce qu'on est aussi
on est aussi là pour ça
c'est une opération de communication
tesla évidemment la société des lots de
masques très très fort les véhicules
sauf s'ils sont en majesté jeudi la
presse encore plus que la fusée falcon 9
on voit les voitures tesla en plus avec
ses portes elron façon delorean de
retour vers le futur
vounet dans le futur la crise torgnole
quoi c'est le futur de vie dans les
années soixante dix les on retourne en
reparlera aussi sûrement métalleux il ya
le space toutes les combinaisons
spatiales des astronautes qui ont été
design et par un célèbre célèbre
costumier d'hollywood qui a fait comme
les costumes de certains iron man 2
batman version super man etc
pour la petite histoire il les a
dessinées sans savoir que c'était
destiné à être des vrais combinaisons
spatiales donc c'est pour ça qu'on
dirait vraiment des combinaisons de
films c'est qu'elles ont été faits par
quelqu'un qui ne pensais pas que ce
serait donc une vraie combinaisons
spéciales elles sont hyper technologique
l'intérieur de la capsule aussi la fac
online là qui va décoller var et
atterrir donc c'est des fameux lancement
réutilisables donc on va aussi voir ça
voilà c'est vraiment le futur allez on
prend vos questions et vos commentaires
rendant les semaines n'hésitent pas à
passer le plus souvent possible en plein
écran sur les images de la nasa
puisqu'on vit le direct le visage de
tristan est très très beau mais ce qu'on
aime voir nous ce sont les images des
astronautes donc n'hésite pas à le
passer en plein écran une question de
dominique pourquoi les réservoirs sont
il remplit juste avant le décollage
parce que c'est vrai que là on est dans
la phase de remplissage disant avoir
peut-être qu'elle est déjà terminée
alors ils viennent de prendre la
décision en principe de
de ces terres 11h04 donc un principe ils
deviennent pas de prendre la décision de
remplir les réservoirs
il ya le ont rempli en kérosène en
oxygène liquide à la dernière minute
parce qu' on essaie d'éviter tout autant
que faire ce peu d'avoir des des
techniciens du monde en fait autour du
pas de tir au nom du remplissage parce
que c'est un moment un peu risqué une
fusée c'est un espèce de pétards géant
c'est une bombe
quelque part contrôler donc on essaie de
le faire à la dernière minute
pour prendre le moins de risques
possibles donc là c'est à peu près voilà
quarante cinq minutes avant le décollage
et en cas de problème on peut garder les
réservoirs remplis un certain temps pas
éternellement non plus je pense qu'ils
peuvent tenir jusqu'à un lancement
demain mais voilà seraient ils peuvent
aussi être vidangées pour être remplie
voilà on évite au maximum
voilà de 2,2 mètres d en péril la vie
des gens qu'on attend que le pas de tir
soit quitter par la plupart des
opérateurs d'ailleurs le dernier
accident de d'une fusée space x était
sur le pas de tir
alors justement c'était en 2016 et elle
avait explosé voilà sans faire de sans
faire de victime justement parce que le
remplissage se fait juste avant le
décollage il ya personne sur le pas de
tir et c'est bon là il ya des
astronautes à bord ça n'arrive pas
justement on a une question à un
commentaire sur le chat de cat's eyes 07
13 camille à ce sujet qui me dit j'ai
pas mal de problèmes et de loupés avec
space x si je ne m'abuse non pas mal de
louper non on peut pas vraiment dire ça
il y en a eu un petit peu
forcément les premières années parce que
c'est une fusée toute nouvelle est que
la philosophie de ce pays fixe c'est
d'essayer d'essayer d'essayer quitte à
voir des kits avoir des convois le
direct en voit donc c'est la rampe
d'accès à la capsule qui est donc qu'ils
aient retiré 1 exactement comme prévu
c'était prévu à 5,1 11h07 il est 11
heures 06 donc avec une minute d'avancé
sur le sur le timing je pense pas qu'en
revanche le lancement lui ce sera avec
une nuit qui sera vraiment à l'heure
précise en principe là ce sont les
images en direct alors qu'ils avaient de
cap canaveral en floride la fusée que
vous voyez ici est bien évidemment celle
qui a à son bord thomas pesquet et son
équipe à et l'équipage qui accompagne sa
chanteuse puisqu'elle n'est pas le
commandant de cette mission va y revenir
un petit peu après je prends d'abord
cette question de tamar de la pampa sur
le chat du figaro.fr
si tu as soif est ce que tu peux tu
hydrater entre maintenant et les ss en
gros là pendant leur voyage
est-ce qu'ils vont avoir le loisir de
pouvoir boire manger
oui bien sûr il ya 23 heures de vol donc
23 ans ça répond à la question de
raphaël c'est après 23h alors après il
ya les opérations de
d'amarrage et d'ouverture du saas prenne
un peu de temps donc après en fonction
de si on compte le moment où la capsule
touche la station la maman il rentre
dedans et un décalage de 2 après 2
heures donc débourser 23 heures va dire
de vols soit à peu près le temps de
faire 16 fois le tour de la terre pour
la capsule il faut pas voir le vol
spatial comme étant un vol vertical
c'est un vol vraiment horizontale autour
de la terre la fusée part à la verticale
au début pour s'affranchir de
l'atmosphère donc elle part à la
verticale et très rapidement elle se
couche et elle part à l'horizontale et
le but ça va être de poursuivre la
station spatiale internationale pour se
mettre petit à petit à son à son niveau
en fonction montrent très très
légèrement jusqu'à ce que m à la même
vitesse et c'est ça qui donne cette
impression de du spatial qu'on a pu voir
en 2001 de de deux choses qui vont très
doucement une par rapport à l'homme ça
les mamans relatif voilà très très lent
en fait les deux objets montrés très
vite par rapport à la terre des enfants
16 fois le tour par jour donc comme les
23 heures de voyage sera présent de
faire 15 16 tours de la terre derrière
la station pour la rattraper et ça on va
le voir maintenant dans quarante et une
minutes vous avez le décompte en haut à
gauche ici plutôt de de cette
réalisation que vous propose la nasa et
renan luce blaise ici pour le figaro on
continue à prendre vos questions et vos
commentaires celle de jordan à gauche
sur le chat youtube qui le dit a est ce
que les fusées lancement reviennent au
même endroit ou sur une autre plate
forme parce que ça en est une des
particularités des lanceurs space x
ils reviennent sur terre il se pose dans
des séquences toujours très
spectaculaire on va voir la fusée
décoller puis se reposer
est-ce que ça va être le cas ici et
surtout et ce sera au même endroit alors
ou à la fois oui oui mais pas exactement
au même endroit donc
oui le la fusée va revenir le retour est
prévu à 5 heures à 11h58 donc neuf
minutes seulement après le décollage
oui au même endroit à cap canaveral pas
exactement sur le même pas de tir alors
j'ai pas la géométrie et la géographie
très particulière en tête
là ce sera je pense à quelques centaines
de mètres quelques kilomètres sur une
plateforme dédiée je crois pas que ce
soit une récupération en mer mais je
vous avoue que je n'ai pas regardé ce
point particulier crois que ça revient
au sol ça peut être un peu d'effort
revenir en mer sur une barge
je crois quand il danse de cap canaveral
ils reviennent ils reviennent là parce
que c'était ce qu'il y avait c'était un
peu la configuration qu'on avait pu voir
je pas si vous vous rappelez de falcon
nine ça partait d'ici aussi et les deux
les deux boosters latéraux étaient
revenus ensemble au sol je pense que ce
sera le même la même configuration cette
fois ci à les 39 minutes avant le
décollage je vous savez vous qu'ils nous
rejoignent et dans le tchat sur la page
de une du figaro.fr et sur youtube
bonjour à christian les ont tous à un
bon jour à koro christophe et sur
youtube vous êtes aussi très nombreux
raphaël ont déjà pris votre question
look ilok bienvenu e nîmes sq 33 cette
question de croo christophe alors plutôt
un commentaire de croxteth intéressante
qui nous dit quel camouflet pour le
programme spatial européen space x fort
des subventions énormes du gouvernement
réalise notre impuissance pour préciser
un peu la question de coraux christophe
avant en 2016 thomas pesquet il avait
décollé sur soyouz oui donc sur un
lanceur russe dans une navette russe
aujourd'hui il décolle sur une fusée
américaine privée le commandant de la
mission est américain la pilote de la
fusée est aussi américaine thomas
pesquet il est là mais c'est pas lui qui
va qui vas tu seras le commandant de la
mission en tout cas pas tout de suite
c'est un truc américain aujourd'hui le
l'espace le programme spatial européen
c'est fini non non c'est fait il faut
pas voir les choses exactement comme ça
disons que l'europe n'a jamais investi
dans un programme de vols habités
jamais
il ya eu des tentatives de navettes dans
les années 90 ha nam et hermès porté
notamment par la france mais qui a été
abandonnée en 92 ça coûte très cher le
choix de l'europe a été plutôt
d'investir sur l'observation de la terre
la science est pas sur le vol habité
donc on n'a jamais envoyer un astronaute
par nos propres moyens dans l'espace ont
un accès indépendant à l'espace avec
ariane 5 aujourd'hui ariane 6 et vega un
partenariat aussi avec soyouz dont on
tire des fusées en guyane le choix
politique a été fait de ne pas investir
dans le vol habité les industriels
européens seraient ravis de le faire on
a certaines technologies qui
permettraient de le faire fabriquer une
capsule habitable c'est pas trop un
problème la lancée ça devrait aller
aussi
le problème c'est la rentrée
atmosphérique il faut un bouclier de
rentrée atmosphérique c'est des
technologies qu'on ne maîtrise pas bien
en europe à ce jour sur lesquels il ya
une navette expérimental qui s'appelle
space riders qui a été dans le
financement a été validé lors de la
dernière ministériel qui le descendant
d'un navet expérimental qui s'appelait
xv et et qui permet de tester justement
cette technologie de rentrée
atmosphérique
donc l'europe pourrait mettre en place
un pouvoir de vols habités
seulement ça coûte cher et la question
est pourquoi faire donc le l'option qui
est prise par l'europe c'est plutôt de
de s'embarquer avec les américains avec
les russes
mais voilà c'est avec la chine un
programme de vols habités l'inde a des
velléités la russie a toujours son accès
indépendant les états unis on retrouvait
là avec rodrigo d'un accès indépendant
ils ont une autre capsule boeing
starliner qui va voler la fin de l'année
il ya la capsule orion qui va aussi volé
la fin de l'année voilà c'est sûr que
alors on a beaucoup de questions et de
commentaires notamment sur la page
youtube de figaro live je vais faire
deux questions en une à partir ces deux
commentaires de le renard bleu et de
nîmes ce que 33 le renard bleu qui ne
demandent quel est le but de la mission
est nîmes ce qu'ils demandent quelles
seront les missions recherche
expériences sur des matériaux réalisé
par par pesquet donc le but de la
mission et les expériences menées par
thomas pesquet alors le but de la
mission basse et déjà d'aller dans l'
iss thomas pesquet va y passer six mois
il prendra le commandement cet été de la
station spatiale internationale ce qui
est une première pour un français cet
été à la faveur de la rotation
d'équipage voilà les les les équipages
se relaie part par wagons de 3% use et
de quatre maintenant pour space x qui
sont 7 à bord avec un roulement et donc
sur une mission une mission un
astronaute connaît deux équipages
différents donc thomas pesquet va faire
des expériences scientifiques il va
faire 12 expérience pour le compte de
l'agencé spatiale française et une
centaine pour le compte à la fois de
l'agencé spatiale européenne et de la
nasa
donc c'est un peu compliqué de rentrer
dans le détail de chacune des
expériences bon quelques petits trucs
fait pour la france il va emporter un
blob avec lui qui est un être vivant ni
réellement animal ni réellement végétale
un peu hybride pour voir comment il se
comporte
en apesanteur il va effectuer des tests
de casques de réalité virtuelle
parce que voilà on est à 2-1 pesanteur
est un excellent remettre dedans donc ça
se comporte de manière un peu différente
pour voir si peu s'ils peuvent
l'utiliser pour faire du sport pour que
ce soit un petit peu moins répétitif il
va faire des mecs pensent de physiologie
il emporte notamment des petits-enfants
choisissent de bien occuper nos cerveaux
et des dispenses de physique de chimie
reprend des expériences pour été fait
avant pour l'équipe qui m'a valu un
petit peu et après qui va transmettre au
suivant c'est un laboratoire qui
fonctionnent en permanence et le but de
ces expériences et en grande partie
quand même d'occuper aussi les
astronautes
parce que le vrai but de lee ss c'est
pas simplement un laboratoire de ses
skis a devancé par toutes les agences
spatiales le but de lee ss c'est de
vivre en apesanteur c'est symbolique ça
fait 20 ans qu'elle occupe en permanence
que l'humanité en collaboration
internationale un pied dans l'espace
constamment on apprend à vue dans
l'espace avec l'idée que même si on veut
un jour faire une base lunaire
c'est toute cette expérience qu'on a
acquise nous servira voilà donc l'aspect
scientifique et il ya déjà quelques
expériences qui sont intéressantes et à
des résultats scientifiques à des
publications etc
les astronautes sont occupés avec toutes
ces expériences mais je pense qu'il faut
pas perdre de vue que le but de lee ssc
avant tout d'occuper l'espace de manière
internationale de maintenir des
technologies de rendez vous spatial
voilà d'apprendre à vivre dans l'espace
en fait d'apprivoiser cet environnement
c'est ça le premier but et donc thomas
pesquet va pas passer six mois six
nouveaux mois il a pris en un peu
d'ailleurs cette deuxième mission parce
qu'il en a déjà fait une haie il sait
quel point c'est difficile de passer six
mois dans l'espace
il ya des moments très agréables je
pense qu'il y en a d'autres beaucoup
plus difficile il a mené de nombreuses
interviews dans laquelle il dit qu'il se
sent plus en forme que j'avais plus en
forme que jamais le poids des le poids
des années
il a 43 ans oui il a dit avant ce
week-end on a énormément de questions
tristan que je vous soumets ici
notamment déjà sur le sur le voyage
est ce qu'ils vont avoir à manger à
boire sans a déjà répondu est ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir se changer et ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir dormir durant ces 23 heures
de voyage est ce qu'ils se relèvent
ou est-ce que personne ne dort oui ils
vont ils vont dormir 23 heures c'est
long maintenant ils vont bien sûr de
revenir alors de temps le dans la
capsule soyouz il ya deux modules il ya
le module dans laquelle ils sont assis
un peu à l'étroit et celui qu'on voit
pas qu'à un module séparer de vie donc
du coup ils peuvent un peu se répartir
après le décollage entre les deux
modules et avoir un peu d'intimité
fabrique peuvent rien il fallait dormir
avec les deux autres restent dans le
module de pilotage
là c'est un seul volume plus grand que
l'ensemble des deux soyouz mais un seul
volume
ils peuvent évidemment dormir en
apesanteur pas vraiment besoin d'eux a
vraiment besoin de ce salon j'ai deux
salles blanches et rouges partout on est
à londres et dans après 360 voilà donc
je précise je précède autre histoire
déjà fait à deux présentant pas
suffisamment la vidéo on peut voir sur
fillon l'avait d'ailleurs si vous
retrouvez la violer pas suffisamment
pour dormir mais nos vallées où on va
dormir et ou pas manger un peu boire
il y à des toilettes dans cette capsule
alors si on a très peu d'informations
dessus alors quels qu'ils soient qui ont
été posées les américains là dessus sont
comment dire
il n'aime pas parler très pudique très
pudique part indiqué du coup voilà c'est
un peu tabou mais on sait que au plafond
de la au plafond de la tendance ne le
fait pas le derrière comme il faut
appeler sam et le le laissons de plafond
et le plancher a plus vraiment de soins
et semelle mais il ya un an connaître
les préviens tout l'espace yalda
pesanteur donc c'est c'est des choses
qui fonctionnent généralement avec un
aspect il ya une aspiration les
astronautes entre eux c'est quelque
chose dont il parle de maximiser la
raconter avant de partir la première
fois voilà comment est ce qu'on fait
cliquer dans l'espace comment ce qu'on
fait pipi
voilà c'est une question qui se pose et
dont ils parlent entre eux
il donne des trucs injustement pour
éviter les accidents entre guillemets
voilà du pipi qui flottent etc
c'est pas très ragoûtant que bon c'est
s'est satisfait sur le plan créatif
c'est vrai question est qu'il faut
prendre en compte et qui sont vraiment
importantes et du coup ils échangent
entre eux mais il ya un espèce de plis
beaudry pour en parler à l'extérieur
beaucoup de questions dans le chat je le
disais on est maintenant à 30 minutes de
ce décollage que nous allons vivre en
direct avec vous ces questions de l'eau
qui lobe dans quelle mesure les
passagers de la fusée donc l'équipage
auquel participent thomas pesquet
contrôle-t-il le vol
est-ce que tout est automatisé au
contrôle et de cap canaveral alors c'est
pas vraiment contrôlé à mon sens de
capitaine à g et c'est relativement
automatisés tout est intégré dans la
capsule plus programme de vol etc
les astronautes sont là pour surveiller
que tout se déroule correctement donc là
ils ont des écrans tactiles très large
qui synthétise toute cette information
là qui leur dit voilà les systèmes de
vie sont ok l'oxygène ça va le jeu
parler les moteurs les moteurs d'urgence
fonctionne correctement voilà on peut
imaginer un avion une voiture dans
laquelle il ya plein de systèmes
électroniques embarqués et il ya un
retour qui vous disent voilà au hasard
une tesla bryant et slaves et un écran
qui vous dit ben voilà tout va bien quoi
tout va bien le réservoir est plein il
n'y a pas de fuite
la pression est ok tout et nominales et
c est donc là c'est des écrans qui vont
montrer cette information là de manière
très synthétique
un peu comme sur une nappe de votre de
votre téléphone vous auriez des carrés
verts en disant ok ok tchèque et c'est
sur le lasso news c'était voilà plein de
l'indicateur analogique des petits
boutons un peu comme un comme dans un
avion là l'image qu'on a d'un avion avec
tous ces petits boutons et des petites
lumières etc et il faut un peu
interpréter les informations
là c'est beaucoup plus simple voilà
après s'il ya un problème il ya
possibilité de reprendre le contrôle de
certains éléments
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya une pilote et
un commandant de bord en cas de en cas
de problème pour blache pas déclencher
une procédure d'urgence reprendre le
contrôle de la capsule est de résoudre
un problème en principe de respect c'est
de manière automatique
c'est tout ce déroule correctement à
l'esa berthomé ses invités qui nous
demandent mars
est ce que c'est possible un jour est ce
qu'un jour on veut rattraper ce qu'est
sur mars
ah bon alors thomas pesquet un jour sur
mars non 1-1 et rappelé combien d'êtres
humains sur mars
un jour oui un être humain sur mars de
notre vivant
là vraiment les deux je ne m'avancerai
pas c'est très difficile il ya plein de
choses compliquées pour un voyage sur
mars
déjà il faut être capable d'en revenir
nos que va live et les projets un peu
fous d'envoyer des êtres humains sur
mars pour y vivre pour y vivre sans
ticket de retour ça en vérité j'y crois
pas trop même s'il y avait plein de
volontaires je vois personne réellement
faire ça et voilà après il faut en
revenir il faut aussi un intérêt
un intérêt pour y aller donc les faire
de la science monter une base
voilà ce qu'on risque de voir de notre
vivant c'est une base sur la lune
habitait alors peut être habité d'abord
par une une station en orbite autour de
la lune et des allers retours vers la
surface et peut être un jour une vraie
station sur la lune habite et ça ça j'y
crois mais pour le reste voilà je pense
qu'on n'aura pas on risque de pas avoir
de deux missions habitées vers mars à
mon avis de notre visant miss licorne
qui nous parle sur le chat youtube d'une
lune rose prévue le 27 avril
effectivement il doit y avoir une super
lune qui est annoncé pour le 27 avril et
qui demandent si la paix ce qui va
pouvoir en profiter alors le 27 avril il
sera plus dans la capsule dragon il sera
dans les sss que de publier celle ci va
avoir la chance d'observer ce phénomène
alors je sais pas exactement ce que
c'est que la ville rose était tellement
de lune qui ont des noms la lune bleue
la super lune la lune bidule abus de
machin
de toute façon voilà c'est une pleine
lune et une pleine lune et il peut tout
à fait voir je pense depuis l' iss il
faut que le blue shade tournée de ce
côté là avec la même chance avec un peu
de chance et il va il va voir ça il
pourra voir sa voix cristalline tout ça
sur le chat du figaro qui nous dit
quelle information complète on
s'enrichit de détails de la mission
signée tristan vous avez les
félicitations de christian miron né à 26
minutes et 37 secondes de ce décollage
que nous allons vivre ensemble on
commence à voir
tristan une fumée qui se dégage des
réacteurs de falcon ça veut dire que le
lancement est en cours est ce qu'à ce
stade il peut encore être annulée oui
bien sûr il peut être le lancement peut
être annulés jusqu'à la dernière seconde
il n'y a pas de honte ils prendront
aucun risque de manière générale on
prend aucun risque en fait un lancement
quand il habitait évidemment je veux
dire encore moins mais d'autres façons
on ne prend pas de risques de l'ansés
il ya plein de systèmes qui sont mis en
place pour arrêter automatiquement
lancement à la moindre anomalie
ce qu'on voit comme la fumée là c'est le
ya le remplissage d'oxygène liquide et
donc voilà c'est ça qui peut émettre un
peu de un peu de fumée quand le gaz
s'évapore c'est leur unique et de manu
très très froid
et voilà c'est une des toutes petites
gouttelettes elle seule sa crise or le
fumé fasse absolument normal ok on a
plusieurs personnes dans le dos dans le
chat qui nous demandent non sans ironie
gelade et celle notamment de jordan a vu
ce qu'était ce que les astronautes ont
été vaccinées files heures avant le vol
j'imagine souhaitez accéder quand même
contrôle qualité ouais ouais ils ont été
vaccinés les les quatre astronautes ont
été vaccinés contre le covin qu'ils ont
reçu leurs deux injections je pense même
qu'ils les ont reçu assez tôt je sais
pas exactement quel moment ils ont été
vaccinées mais mais se vacciner alors il
faut savoir que
c'est passé cette partie on va dire les
instantes quoi qu'il arrive dans les dix
quinze jours avant le lancement ils sont
isolés ils voient que des médecins qui
les tchèques tous les jours on veut à
tout prix éviter d'en porter un
astronaute malades
encore une fois c'est pas très ragoûtant
mais monter un astronaute qui une gastro
entérite dans l'espace et c'est la
catastrophe s'est jamais arrivé ce
serait la catastrophe qui contaminerait
cesser ses collègues il ya qu un
toilette dans l'espace
voilà on peut imaginer tout ce que ça
pourrait mais voilà même un astro grippe
est là haut ce serait serait la
catastrophe la catastrophe
tout est relatif mais la problématique
de la cimo la cipres il monte les copies
de là haut il faudrait probablement tous
les faire descendre
voilà serait compliqué on se trouve et
désinfecter la station enfin voila se
seraient ils veulent éviter ça à tout
prix le vaccin c'est une sécurité
supplémentaire notamment parce que les
astronautes quand même des gens qui ont
besoin de voyager d'aller se former aux
expériences qui vont réaliser dans les
différentes dans les différents à la
nasa les a donc on a le match en main et
agences il rencontre des gens des
scientifiques externe donc ils ont quand
même des contacts humains donc ils ont
réduit au maximum justement ces
entraînements ils ont fait le maximum en
visio etc
mais voilà ils vont ils ont évidemment
été vaccinées après x fighters du
moderna d'astrazeneca j'en ai aucune
idée
j'aurais tendance à dire comme ça qu'ils
ont probablement pris du plaisir parce
que c'était le premier qu'il est
disponible mais vrai il aurait très bien
pu être vaccinés qu'astrazeneca sens
sans aucun risque et ils sont là
l'équipage de cette mission être à 100
de la capsule crew dragonne qui va
décoller maintenant dans 23 minutes
ce sera assurée videmment en direct à ce
moment là on va sauter vos tristes en
chine king au premier plan pour
commencer le commandant ensuite juste
derrière il ya la pilote mégane arthur
qui est l'épousé d'un astronaute qui a
fait les vols de test de la capsule
parce que c'est rigolo et au fond
envoyez thomas pesquet est ce qui manque
c'est le japonais
il est en fait devant tchéquie mme braun
qu'on le voit pas sur ce plan là
d'accord en jeu lumière sur le chat ou
demande que se passe-t-il en cas
d'incident la capsule se détache tête de
l'ensemble pour protéger les astronautes
vont déjà des incidents il pourrait y
avoir de nombreux plus ou moins graves
tout dépend de la nature de l'incident
mais en cas d' en fait il ya ya ya eu
bimoteur c'est votre super draco qui
équipe là alors ils sont ils sont sur
les bords de la les voir on voulait
montrer sur les bords de la capsule
alors il dans ils sont là où je voulais
montrer autant de la capsule
oui je voulais montre hop ils sont ici
ok ils sont par paire de 2 hockey est
donc là en k2 en cas d'incident grave
mettons la fusée commence à partir à
partir a pas su que sa trajectoire
nominale c'est moteur s'allume sa éjecte
la capsule les astronautes prennent un
coup de un bon coup dans le dos
supplémentaires et ensuite la capsule a
atterri de manière safe en mer
son parachute c'est à dire la raison
pour laquelle le lancement a été reporté
de 24 heures c'est qu'il y avait un
mauvais temps en mer et en cas de
problème
la capsule aurait atterri dans une mer
agitée ce qu'on veut à tout prix éviter
on préfère une mer relativement calme
des conditions météorologiques
tranquille en cas de problème pour
pouvoir récupérer la capsule c'est ça
qui avait conduit à l'annulation ou le
report de 24 heures les questions de
genre lanthier sur le chat youtube qu'on
salue en quoi consiste exactement le
rôle du commandant de l'iss est ce qu'on
a vu il dire voilà ce qu'on voit c'est
pas mal d'essais ce jeu où kim bros
alors oui c'est vrai pardon sa question
exacte c'est du commandant à bord de bss
donc je pense qu'il parle de shane kim
gros convoi alors jean-louis les
commandes la capsule il est pas
commandant de l'équipage en fait mais en
gros quand vous avez un vaisseau spatial
l'insee considère comme un vaisseau
spatial la capsule est un vaisseau
spatial
il faut une personne qui prennent la
décision finale et c'est le commandant
c'est comme dans un avion le commandant
de bord
il a un copilote qui peut tout à fait
piloté d'avion mieux que lui mais s'il
ya une décision à prendre alors dans le
cadre d'un avion ça on comprend mieux
ces décisions là mais dans un avion
béton qui file voilages pas éviter un
ouvrage etc c'est le commandant de bord
qui prend la décision de dire voilà on
va détourner l'avion on va le poser ici
on vraiment de risque s'il ya un
incident et c'est le rôle dans la
capsule c'est exactement le même s'il ya
enfin trois heures de trajet la capsule
on imagine mal un un un conflit entre
les entre les gens mais bon mettons
qu'il ya un problème particulier qui
failli se relayer pour faire une tâche
et serra c'est le commandant de bord qui
va dire toi tu fais ça toi tu fais ça
toi tu fais c'est notamment à la pilote
megan mcarthur aller les pilotes donc
elle est là elle a une formation plus
avancés sur le pilotage même de la
capsule donc celle du pilote mais si une
décision à prendre et c'est elle doit
elle doit suivre
donc le l'ordre de son de son commandant
de bord donc qui chine qui brille
généralement un asthme et expérimenté
chine qui mosquée le commandant de deux
lits ss quand la deuxième partie de la
première mission de sauver ce que je
faisais cette voie là de 17 en 2010 est
exactement les conditions super météo
super important nous rappelle quatre
sages on se souvient de l'accident de
challenger et pour tous les internautes
qui demandent à quelle heure est prévu
le décollage s'est 11h49 l'heure du
décollage
vous avez sur les images la réalisation
nasa et celle de rodez le décompte voilà
19 minutes maintenant dans dix neuf
minutes nous assisteront ensemble à ce
décollage en attendant on continue à
prendre vos questions et vos
commentaires alors qu'on voit thomas
pasquet particulièrement ceux ayant sur
ces photos d'introduction encore plus
que les autres membres de l'équipage de
cette mission crew 2 je continuais
pardon à prendre vos questions et vos
commentaires du coup j'ai perdu le j'ai
perdu le fil la question que je voulais
prendre voilà une question pour daniel 6
ans qui demandait ce que les astronautes
peuvent écouter de la musique dans la
fusée alors je crois que oui bien sûr
alors pianiste
ils ont une playlist qu'ils ont en
principe alors je crois qu'ils écoutent
tous la même chose ils ont pas chacun
leur playlist ma connaissance dans
jeunes alors il a décidé en principe en
commun et il faut savoir qu'ils ont un
ils ont des des écouteurs intégrés dans
leurs quatre nouvelles combinaisons
permettre de communiquer avec le bord
mais aussi d'écouter de la musique alors
il ya évidemment des moments
où il ya des opérations qui sont menées
et donc du coup voilà il s'enfuit les
opérations techniques d'écouté de
musique mais à des moments de temps mort
ça fait ils sont montés dans la dans la
capsule
je vous dise pas de bêtises il ya un peu
plus de deux heures je crois on avait
les images ont peut-être que si renan
les messes à la réalisation les a on va
pouvoir il ya un peu plus de deux heures
romain c'est ya quand même quelques
temps mort au début il ya pas mal de
deux choses qui sont on va dire qu'ils
sont vérifiés au sort les installe
ils sont assez passifs et voilà c'est ça
ce serait quelques heures alors ça
c'était voilà c'est au centre de
contrôle c'est avant qu'ils aillent qui
prennent la tesla s'il ya vingt minutes
de trajet puis monte dans la capsule
et c'est après voilà de deux heures
avant le lancement et le caddie à des
temps morts et donc à ce moment là ils
peuvent écouter de la musique il en
principe mail en terme de musique les
listes communes il me semble que
notamment la pilote macarthur avait dit
qu'elle avait choisi foo fighters ouais
c'est le gris des jeux croatie si vous
allez voir ils se mettent d'accord ça
fait partie des choses qui permettent de
souder l'équipage est qui qui se
décident avant il ya aussi après voilà
il ya un certain nombre de rituels
pré-lancement dont font partie
évidemment le choix de la musique
ils ont aussi une petite ils ont aussi
choisi une petite peluche qu'on n'a pas
encore vu qui va servir d'indicateur de
zéro gravité et qui va se mettre à
flotter en fait au moment où la capsule
va se se détacher du deuxième étage de
la fusée sera de 12 minutes après le
décollage environ donc on découvrira
quelle est l'identité de cette petite de
cette petite de cette petite peluche
voilà l'un sinon le rituel humala thomas
pesquet pour son dernier alors ils
disent pas dernier repas ultime repas
avant le décollage de la main du poulet
avec de la purée
le soldat puristes vous êtes un fait
étonnant sachant quoi manger il faut
manger que ça il doit beaucoup aimé la
purée c'est pas et ils m'ont dit ça
parce que dans les ff évidemment ses
pastèques fripes
non il ya quelques repas un peu
d'exceptions d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
thomas pesquet emporte avec lui des
quelques boîtes de conserves composé par
thierry marx
il ya des voilà des crêpes suzette du
boeuf bourguignon et c'est donc quelques
plats un peu de de fait il va notamment
ce qui a passé noël
non il va passer noël mais bon il ya
quand même des plats de varices et
commentent en direct six mois six mois
mais il ya quand même des tas de voilà
des plats on va dire un peu d'exception
mais sinon moi c'est des plaintes liées
aux phillies et c'est la nourriture un
peu d'être un petit peu lassante
avec le temps aller retour au direct
c'est maintenant dans un tout petit peu
plus de 15 minutes que nous allons
assister au décollage de cette fusée
falcon 9
embarquant à son bord cette capsule
dragon en bas record à son bord le
français thomas pesquet pour son
deuxième séjour dans l'île et cesse dans
15 minutes
le décompte bien évidemment on va le
vivre ensemble avec les images il y
avait un truc est demandé est ce que
c'est que des commentateurs dans c'est
du direct les images que voyait son en
direct de cap canaveral en floride et
dans 15 minutes maintenant on va suivre
décollage je continue à prendre vos
questions et vos commentaires en
attendant a notamment cette question de
jc sous l'assaut youtube qui nous devant
bonjour est il possible d'envisager des
missions pour nettoyer les mines
et de débris en orbite ou est ce qu'ils
attendent de ne plus pouvoir passer au
travers bon sang on sent quand même
j'essaie soula concernés par cette
question là d'écologie dans l'espace
tristan oui alors il ya plusieurs répond
alors des missions pour récupérer les
tout petits débris qui se comptent par
millions des millions de débris de moins
d'un centimètre dans l'espace il ya peu
de chance c'est très compliqué ce qui
est plutôt envisagé c'est démission
capable d'aller chercher les gros
morceau qui traîne pour les ramener les
donc ça peut être d'anciens étage de
fusée
ça peut être deux d'anciens satellites
de télécommunications qui n'ont pas été
qui n'ont pas été désorbitée il faut
savoir que voilà au delà de 1000 km
d'altitude les débris enfin les
satellites m extrêmement longtemps à
descendre si on les ramène pas en gros
ça leur donne pas un petit coup de main
pour les pour les ramener
donc ça il ya des milliers d'îles en mai
dernier des projets qui sont en cours
pour essayer de voilà les harponner les
rappeler avec un filet et c'est pour
ensuite les à les ramener vers la terre
et qui se désintègre dans le dans
l'atmosphère pour les plus petits débris
pour l'instant y'a rien de prévu et
c'est un vrai problème
une étude assez récente en 2019 vous
pouvez lire un papier là dessus dans le
figaro de demain qui montrait que on
estime que sur 10 ans
soit dix prochaines années il ya une
chance sur 60 pour qu'un astronaute
meurent du fait d'une collision avec un
peptide évolué dans les ss donc c'est
pas c'est pas anecdotique ce n'est pas
anodin
la multiplication des satellites
notamment de space x avec starlink la
constellation wan web
c'est des dizaines de milliers de petits
satellites risque d'augmenter le nombre
de débris en orbite basse
en dessous de 50 500 km donc voilà c'est
un c'est un vrai problème le la solution
c'est moins d'aller nettoyer ce que ça
peut paraître beaucoup mais en fait faut
voir que mon espace est quand même très
grand et donc très vide si on prend un
cube on va dire de 200 km de côtes et on
trouve un objet qui fait la taille d'un
la taille de ce mug là dans un cube 200
km de côtes et c'est relativement vide
quand même faut pas si on voit les
images avec spes de multitudes débris
parce que forcément sur les images on
fait un point pour voir le point mais il
a il est assez gros le point il serait
en fait un kilomètre
c'est évidemment pas un débris d'un
kilomètre donc en fait l'espace rester
assez vide pour l'instant cdc un risque
qui arrive à être gérés mais ça
nécessite par exemple pour les ss
plusieurs manoeuvres chaque année pour
éviter pour changer d'altitude pour
éviter un débris
et une fois par an environ les
astronautes ont une alerte dernière
minute et vont se réfugier dans les les
capsules prêt à quitter le vaisseau de
manière voilà deux ans en urgence donc
ça arrive une fois par an donc c'est que
c'est pas c'est pas anodin c'est pas non
allez on est à 12 minutes maintenant de
ce décollage aura beaucoup de questions
et de commentaires de plus en plus
nombreux et nombreuses à nous rejoindre
pour cela et vous en remercie dans dix
minutes
nous allons assister à ce décollage qui
on continuera après on suivra évidemment
le l'avancée de la fusée dans l'espace
pour les retardataires un petit point le
voyage valait cesse va durer 23 heures
plusieurs personnes qui nous le nous le
demande la question sur comment est ce
qu ils font leurs besoins on a déjà
répondu tout à l'heure assez longuement
donc je vous invite à regarder le replay
juste après la vidéo pour avoir la
réponse à cette question
et puis on a celle ci de lui céder qui
nous demandent est ce que vous
connaissez la vitesse de la fusée pour
sortir de l'atmosphère tristan alors la
vitesse de libération je la connais par
coeur ses onze kilomètres par seconde
donc après vous vous le super 3600 pour
avoir en kilomètres par heure donc ça
fait à peu près trente six mille
kilomètres heure si je ne dis pas de
bêtises n'hésitez pas à me corriger
raccrocher tristan si le nul en maths
voilà après j'ai pas le détail de la
création je sais que le les efforts
mécanique sur la fusée ces deux minutes
après le décollage qui sont maximaux
voilà donc c'est le moment le plus
intense en termes d'accélération pour
les astronautes je sais que le ces le en
fait au moment où le deuxième étage
s'allume
il s'agit de me faire beaucoup plus
raréfier et donc du coup l'accélération
est assez fortement ressenti aussi
voilà ça vous donne des ordres de
grandeur mais bon ça va vite on a cette
question d'alexis dans alexis combalbert
dans le châtelineau demande est-ce que
ça le premier vol de space x vers les ss
non c'est pas le deuxième c'est le
troisième vol de space x vers l' iss il
y avait un premier vol qui sait
peut-être des modeuses que tu es un vol
test dont qui les attend de surmonter
pour aller s'arrimer regarder que tous
vers le marché bien qu'ils sont
redescendus et c'est le deuxième vol du
coût opérationnel il ya un équipage qui
est en ce moment même à bord de l' iss
et d'ailleurs ils vont se croiser la
capsule l'as dragons crew 2 qui
s'appelle en des amours en hommage à la
fois la navette spatiale endavour faut
pas confondre et eau et aux bateaux de
james kool xviiie siècle donc ça fait un
bail espèce d'héritage plusieurs
affaires des références à des références
à des références bouddhique et il ya une
aucune autre capsule qui est à bord et
les quatre astronautes de descendre on
le 28 avril
en principe donc que dans 5 jours et ce
sera la preuve la deuxième fois
seulement que la capsule que la capsule
crew dragon effectué une rentrée
atmosphérique donc c'est pas une capsule
qui a beaucoup volé
et celle la capsule en avant dans
laquelle thomas pesquet en ce moment
c'est celle qui était utilisée pendant
le premier vol de démonstration
donc elle est réutilisé d'accord c'est
pas une capsule perd rien chez space x
tout ça aurait été l'espèce mais c'est
que tout se récupère qu'elle soit
intéressante je trouve deux victoires du
bois ten sur le chat youtube qu'on salue
clairement pourquoi est ce que cela
prend plus de temps pour space x que
pour soyouz qui ne prend environ que ça
ne prend que environ six heures pour
rallier les ss alors il ya fort à parier
que en fait c'est parce que les premiers
vols de la capsule crude à gombe donc
ils utilisent la procédure lente pour
rejoindre l' iss la capsule soyouz a une
à une procédure accélérée
en fait c'est une question de marge en
fait si vous voulez on peut arriver ans
yzeure allier sait ce que ça veut dire
qu'on prend moins de marge d'erreur pour
l'atteindre
la capsule russe soyouz a fait des
centaines de deux vols donc on allait
très bien maîtrisée et c'est quelque
chose qui a été mis en place avec depuis
j'ai pas date exacte mais j'aurais
peut-être dix ans cette procédure
accélérée qui permet de la tendance isr
elle n'est pas utilisée systématiquement
il des capsules soyouz récemment qu'ils
ont pris la procédure lente
voilà je pense que la capsule américaine
utiliseront aussi une procédure
accélérée pour l'atteindre mais là c'est
les premiers vols donc voilà à leur
temps à les tristes heures le décollage
est maintenant dans moins de huit
minutes 7 minutes 40 secondes exactement
vous voyez peut-être le le timer qui
s'affiche derrière nous pour ce pour ce
décollage les astronautes qui vont
rallier les ss et cette question de eric
h alors que la pression monte de cordes
atelier 16 déjà la destruction iss a été
progressif
c'était progressif le premier lancement
je crois que c'est fin des années 90 je
vais dans des bêtises 99 peut-être
je sais qu'elle est habitée en
permanence depuis plus de 20 ans e
parce qu'au début de sa construction à
l'ap est habitée en permanence c'est les
navettes spatiales américaines qui ont
permis de la deûle à construire dans les
plus gros modules notamment les panneaux
solaires panneaux solaires qui vont être
en partie alors pas changé mais il ya
des bars des sorties pendant la mission
de thomas pesquet pour ajouter de
nouveaux panneaux solaires et du coup
comme on n'avait plus la navette
spatiale
c'est pas la même technologie qui va
être utilisé parce qu'ils les panneaux
solaires de la station sont gigantesques
ils ont utilisé ces deux panneaux
solaires enroulée comme un tapis de yoga
si vous voulez ils vont les dérouler
donc c'est un des panneaux solaires
souples qui vont être mis en place et
donc du coup les la session a pas été
habité en permanence au début mais les
deux puis oui je crois que ses 21 ans il
sent qu'on a fêté les 20 ans l'année
dernière où il ya deux ans on est à un
peu plus de six minutes maintenant six
minutes et 20 secondes du décollage la
pression monte d'ailleurs aussi dans les
commentaires du tchad puisque dan 007 et
il n'est pas le seul
nous demandons combien de % de chances
d'exploser au décollage est ce qu'on
évalue comme ça le risque d'incidents au
décollage ont forcément femmes habilité
jeu pas de manière très officielle en
tout cas jean françois clervoy là soit
français a déclaré j'ai lu ça dans une
nappe reste régional j'aimerais sources
et je crois que c'était dauphiné libéré
je ne m'en voulez pas si je me suis je
vous ai je me suis trompé du rhône a
salué france 2 et voilà mais que c'était
qui dévale usa une chance sur cent
environ
donc voilà c'est qu'on peut faire des
calculs basés sur l'historique le nombre
de vols habités et c'est après des
accidents il n'a pas eu beaucoup il les
deux navettes
américaine une à la rentrée une au
décollage avec sept personnes à bord à
chaque fois il ya eu
lan née il ya deux trois ans une navette
heures une capsule russe qui a dû
utiliser un système d'urgence mais les
astronautes étaient sains et saufs et
pour soyouz je considère la première
fois que dans un vol opérationnel
il y avait un problème il y avait déjà
eu des vols et david et quelques
accidents au tout début de soyouz mais
entre temps il n'est pas une grand chose
pour space x babolat plan signé aucun
aucun échec
ça fait depuis 2016 fin 2015 mais qui
n'ont pas explosé en vol 2016 c'est
excluant sur le pas de tir
à ma connaissance ils n'ont pas eu
d'échec depuis pas d'explosions en tout
cas il ya eu des sons on pense à des
explosions mais c'était généralement des
au moment de revenir le premier étage
moment de revenir sur les barges et
cetera où il tombait il explosait etc
ils n'ont pas eu beaucoup de beaucoup
d'échecs donc c'est assez difficile
c'est pas anodin c'est pas comme prendre
l'avion mais il ya beaucoup plus de
chances pour que pour que pour que ça
marche
voilà allez dans quatre minutes tristan
le décollage bien sûr dans la dernière
minute
on va laisser un run en l'espèce de
réalisateurs de ce live vous passez le
son du décollage le fameux compte à
rebours qu'on vivra ensemble avant de
reprendre la parole juste emprunté les
dernières questions une question de
julie ja djokovic je vis 6 désolé si je
prends ce mal le nom crémant de combien
coûte une mission comme celle ci tristan
assez une c'est la colle je n'ai pas du
tout le chiffre en tête à à la première
personne qui a réussi à que les tristan
sur ce live
non pas la lune bravo bravo à vous c'est
pas si facile usa / bombardons dans ce
cas on pensait que les vérifier et puis
on vous transmettra l'information et des
destins grandeur pour les
les développements à
les dévs le développement de la capsule
après c'était soit 2,4 milliards 4,2
milliards conflit la nasa pour space x
pour développer la capsule avec un
certain nombre de sièges
après ça pas forcément de sens je crois
que pour les soyouz j'ai un chiffre de
l'ordre de 100 millions par par par
capsule mais à vérifier votre peut-être
ça dans les précédents articles du
figaro j'avais dû essayer de nous donner
des prix ces sièges
allez dans trois minutes maintenant ce
décollage vous voyez la fumée maintenant
qui sort de part et d'autre de la fusée
toujours des images moi que je trouve
vraiment très très belle toujours qu'est
ce qu'on voit que ça c'est de la vapeur
c'est pareil c'est comme pour le tout à
l'heure à se placer le deuxième étage
qui est remplie d'oxygène liquide et
donc du coup je pense qu'il ya des
petites espèces et des fuites où ils ont
laissé un peu partir mais bon ca c'est
un peu rempli de manière constante
jusqu'au jusqu'au décollage
là ce qu'on voit ça la capsule dans
laquelle ont pris place la capuche et
voilà il s'est prolongé en dessous ce
qu'on appelle le module de service donc
la partie blanche et noire là qu'on voit
c'est ça qui va propulser la la capsule
pour terminer
terminée la proche de l' iss allait
l'aider à toutes leurs questions
attendre un tout petit peu plus de deux
minutes du décollage une question de
matisse fourni que le mans est ce que
les astronautes vont sortir de la fusée
à un moment ou un autre oui puisque
quand ils vont arriver à l'essai ils
vont devoir passer de la capsule à la
station oui exactement si ce n'est que
par le nez et ça se fait par le nez de
la capsule et comprend la petite
histoire ça a été toute une toute une
histoire exactement c'est juste là et
pour la petite histoire ça a été quelque
chose quand les russes et les américains
ont décidé de s'associer ensemble
il a fallu penser un système pour
justement ce s'accrocher et donc c'est
un système ni mal ni femelle parce que
personne ne voulait que les médias
voulaient pas que sous les russes qui
pénètre le les américains et inversement
donc c'est un système hybride voilà
comme de cloaque de d'animaux qui se
collent l'un à l'autre et qu'ils se
fixent un à l'autre question de guitare
alors qu'on a aimé le 30 maintenant du
décollage quels sont les intérêts de
décoller la nuit on sait pas il n'y a
pas d'intérêt collet la nuit
particulièrement leur est décédé en
fonction c'est de la mécanique orbital
si je vais prendre une image dirait
qu'on attend que lier ça se passe au
dessus pour aller au plus vite
alors évidemment
comme ces de l'orbité qui vont faire 16
fois le tour de la terre je sais pas
exactement si tu lis et c'est ce moment
du décollage
mais l'idée c'est qu'il faut casser dans
une position particulière pour qu'une
fois que le lancement a lieu on minimise
la distance entre les deux allez une
minute pile du décollage que nous allons
vivre ensemble on va progressivement se
terre va progresser moi je même en
classe que si pour entendre évidemment
le décompte avec vous beaucoup
d'internautes qui nous parle des risques
effectivement entrés sans visa l'instant
à % de risques d'explosion sait évaluer
ses évaluer de manière de manière assez
empirique lenny cordier d'ailleurs qui
demandent quel moment le plus risqué du
trajet le décollage clairement le
décollage qu'on va vivre dans un instant
je montre moi même le son du live que
vous êtes en train de vivre j'espère que
renan laisse baisse à la réalisation de
ce live ont fait de même pour vous afin
que vous puissiez en profiter on va
entendre petit à petit le décompte et on
va vous laisser vivre ce moment avec
nous plus d'annulations possible à ce
stade
l'état veut que
caruana
fort
[Musique]
mais presque
m
[Musique]
non
on peut enlever le logo figaro live au
moment où on passe les compteurs pour
qu'on puisse les lire pour les enfants
de plus également les les lire et bien
évidemment fonds fédéraux live mes
capacités
[Applaudissements]
séparation à l'image à l'image du 2e
étage notes à le punir étage s'est
détaché il va c'est lui qui varient la
terrible parce que vous voyez justement
c'est le premier étage est en train de
redescendre et à droite ce que vous
voyez c'est le deuxième étage le moteur
d un étage qui est en train de chauffer
qui est qui propulse le les astronautes
et à gauche était le premier étage qui
fait son retour sur terre ils
accomplissent à sa mission c'est aussi
un état je l'utilisé ya les initiales et
thomas pesquet dessus il les a tracés à
la main les astronautes c'est une
tradition mise en place par space x un
début de tradition un pied trois vols
n'est décrit dans la suie là on a
vraiment passé la partie la plus
critique du décollage c'est à dire qu'il
ya un problème ensuite mais s'il ya des
problèmes ensuite à priori peuvent
revenir sur terre d ampleur venir etc
il ya il ya moins de ce que d'explosion
le premier étage rang revient dans
l'atmosphère d'une certaine façon
alors que le deuxième étage lui est à
170 km déjà vous qu'il ait des gens
l'espace une question d'orient sur le
chat qui nous demandent pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a eu aucune image désastreuse
grotte au décollage je sais pas
exactement c'est un choix de la
réalisation de ce pays que je pourrai
pas vous vous dire particulièrement
peut-être qu'ils démontreront ensuite
peut-être que c'est au cas où il y en a
qui dit-on dans les pommes etc peut pas
faire peur à sa famille pour éviter
aussi je pense en cas de l'accident
d'assister à la mort de personnes en
direct
voilà c'est messi potez je n'ai pas de
type 2 880 comment pourquoi est ce
qu'ils font autant de vitesse pour
passer l'atmosphère c'est papa ça doit
se faire atmosphère c'est juste que
l'atmosphère elle le elle elle freine
donc on essaye de monter le plus vite
possible pour qu'un n'est plus ce qui
permet d'économiser le carburant et où
vous êtes en voiture quoi là qu'ont été
une certaine vitesse seller frottement
de l'air qui vous ralentissent le plus
et donc le but de mon fils et ses deux
le plus vite possible échappée à
l'atmosphère de qui n'étaient à 10 20 30
km d'altitude de l'atmosphère est plus
rare et fier ce qui permet d'être moins
ralenti par le frottement de l'air mais
après ce qui est compliqué c'est
d'échapper à la gravité de la terre et
donc de s'échapper faut imaginer un pub
gravitationnelle et on essaie de s'en
échapper
et pour s'en échapper c'est de la
vitesse latéral qu'il faut qu'il faut
obtenir pour se mettre en orbite est en
fait c'est comme vous imaginez une
cuvette et en fait si on tourne
suffisamment vite dans la cuvette va la
bielle ne retombe pas vers le centre et
le reste elle reste comme ça c'est un
peu le fait un peu sale de l'enfance et
d'être allé assez vite pour pas tomber
dans la cuvette gravitationnelle et il
ya une vitesse au delà de laquelle dans
ce qu'on sort de la cuvette et on
s'arrête pas une vitesse à laquelle on
tourne sans s'arrêter
c'est la vitesse orbitale et c'est ça
que visait la fusée en l'occurrence
quand on va vers mars on essayait de
sortir de la cuve est donc fort et plus
vite
donc voilà la vitesse n'est pas
forcément la même en fonction de ce fait
les plus grosses fusée pour aller sur
mars qu'il faut certains des cuvettes de
l'attert sûr de se placer en orbite
géostationnaire où en orbite basse c'est
pas la même vitesse non plus qu'il faut
atteindre
voilà environ sept minutes que cette
fusée falcon 9 a décollé de cap
canaveral tout s'est passé comme prévu
vous n'êtes que la triste angers
décollage a eu lieu à 11h49 vous l'avez
vu en direct sur les images avec nous du
coup on continue à prendre vos questions
et vos commentaires on va suivre le
début de ce trajet qu'il a duré 23
heures on l'a dit vert vers l' iss avec
notamment cette question de sabrina
clement
les déchets sont ils relâché dans
l'espace alors quels déchets sont ne
relâchant l'espace et moi je rajouterais
une partie la question est ce que comme
avec space x
les lanceurs reviennent sur terre il ya
produit moins de déchets alors pour ce
qui est
du premier étage je pense qu'il
redescend pour tous les lanceurs parce
qu'ils se détachent suffisamment tôt
donc du coup il arrive pas il peut pas
rester en orbite et il retombe de quoi
qu'il arrive
sauf qu'on contrôle pas forcément bien
un endroit où le wii wheel retombe pour
le deuxième étage je vais pas vous dire
de bêtises mais je crois que maintenant
la plupart des alors les chinois je ne
sais pas exactement les russes non plus
mais l'europe et space x en tout cas je
suis à peu près certain qu'ils font en
sorte de désorbiter leur leur deuxième
étage juste après le lancement
donc il rend l'atmosphère et qui se
désintègre il le laisse pas en orbite ce
qu'on faisait avant les premières fusées
jugé j'ai un petit doute sur les
rayonnages sait pas exactement si eux
ils procèdent à ces manoeuvres
les voilà c'est fait partie des bonnes
pratiques qui ont été édictées et il ya
des idées neuves espèce de comité de
travail lié à l'onu qui fait de
d'établir des bonnes pratiques et les
bonnes pratiques c'est justement de metz
et ça vaut pour les satellites aussi
télécommunications et penser alors à
leur fin de vie pour les désorbité et
évidemment les morceaux de fusées en
font partie allez on continue à prendre
vos questions et vos commentaires tout
en suivant en direct le vol qui se
poursuit une question de listes isa qui
le dit un commentaire du se disait
quelques intéressants chaud pourquoi ne
décollerait pas d'un point avec +
d'attitude d'altitude comme par exemple
l'everest est aussi moins d'atmosphère
pour ralentir et du coup pas un vol plus
values facilité je dirais pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne fait pas ça pourquoi est-ce
qu'on décolle proche de l'équateur alors
proche de twitter parce qu'on bénéficie
de la vitesse de rotation qui est plus
importante
au niveau 2 au niveau de l'équateur
parce que c'est voilà donc on essaie de
se rapprocher de ce possible de
l'équateur c'est comme ça que baïkonour
qu'après les américains font que ça sur
leur sol donc ils n'ont pas des quadeurs
mais qui sait faire ça le plus au sud
possible parce que c'est la floride ou
la californie
ensuite en hauteur on s'affranchit raid
1 peut être moins cher je pense pas
qu'on gagne grand chose a tiré à mille à
1 km d'altitude par rapport à tirer au
niveau de la mer un désavantage sur la
côte ouest c'est qu'on décolle vers
l'ouest dont on déconne au dessus de la
mer en cas d'incident c'est plus et
moins risqué voilà la guyane en france
c'est parce que c'est près de l'équateur
près d'équateur aussi donc ok je réponds
aux commentaires de gan qu'il a dit le
présentateur de droite j'imagine que
c'est moi qui pose une question et qui
s'en fout complètement
non c'est pas ça j'ai cru que les
tristan mais je lis aussi vos
commentaires en même temps c'est comme
ça que j'arrive à lui poser des
questions
donc maintenant je me fous de personne
ni de vaud dans le chat ni de réponse de
tristan mais que j'adore ça fait ça va
faire bientôt dix ans qu'on fait des
laïcs comme ça avec tristan n'en croyez
moi je ne m'en fous pas du tout question
de baba qui dit est ce qu'on peut voir
la fusée depuis la france alors la fusée
peut-être pas mais il ya ce sont peu
lisse on peut la suivre il ya des
applications sur votre téléphone qui
permet de vous savoir que faire ce
qu'elle passe au dessus de votre tête
ça fait un petit point brillant alors à
paris on veut être un peu limite pour
l'avoir mais si vous êtes près n'importe
où à la campagne dans un endroit il ya
pas trop de pollution lumineuse
vous pouvez vous pouvez l'a repérée elle
passe régulièrement dans le ciel au
dessus de vous la fusée en l'occurrence
je pense pas qu'on puisse la voir qu'on
puisse la voir depuis la france mais là
ils ont déjà dû
faire un tour un tour de la terre cpt
hâtivement maj labidi la fusée a décollé
11h49
non mais le au début ça va quand même
très vite
bon après il faut il faut regarder j'ai
pas le à petit un petit coucou à voilà
un petit coucou estevan cinq ans qui
laissa pas fait un tour encore un
commentaire le chat pas encore tout à
fait à toi ben voilà là il pour faire un
quart de tour la réponse dans la
réalisation de la nasa et de rolls royce
baisse pour le figaro céline blanc qui
le demandent
question après géopolitiques
stratégiques internationales est-ce que
s'élancent mois avec space x marque une
nouvelle ère de la course à l'espace
notamment avec les russes et les chinois
c'est vrai qu'on a pas mal dit que les
états unis avaient un peu perdu la main
dans leur aventure de la de la conquête
spatiale
et ce qui la reprennent avec space x oui
la reprenne et puis ils changent le il
change le modèle avec avec l'arrivée de
ces entreprises privées alors séparant
les états unis qui changent de modèle
c'est vraiment pour le coup et l'aude
musk et space x alors la nasa a choisi
de l'est de le financer un sens les
finançons danoise a évidemment ce serait
beaucoup plus compliqué mais quand à la
noce qui est arrivé les gens étaient
assez dubitatif
voilà récupérer une fusée pour la
relance et ça paraissait assez incongru
la science fiction
et voilà il a eu une vision et donc il
ay l'impôt et il a guidé quand même
cette vision a quand même pas mal changé
à changer les choses ça peut réduire les
coûts leila sont du coup son projet
starship de vaisseau gigantesque pareil
ça sort complètement des clous de ce
qu'on pouvait faire jusqu'à présent
espèce d'hybride entre la capsule et la
navette spatiale
donc ouais ça change ça change pas mal
les choses les russes et des chinois
sont plus sur des paramètres des
technologies traditionnelles de capsules
je vous laisse découvrir les images
c'est la fin je pense quand même c'est
assez mais ça c'est magnifique quoi
est-ce qu'on peut décrire ce qu'on est
en train de voir la tristan ouais enfin
voir le le module de 2ème étage qui se
séparent ou le service assez assez assez
majestueux pour ses huiles deuxième
étage qui sépare de fait donc c'est la
capsule qu'on voit là qui ce qui sépare
et qui maintenant et est tout seul
donc on voit l'équipage
alors j'avoue qu'on a un prix et de la
buée j'arrive pas ça c'est sûr le à
thomas ps qui nous fait un coeur voilà
avec les doigts et donc lights on y est
ils sont à présent teurs je vois pas la
peluche
le graphique syndicate son convoyage
piloter un peu afin de convoyer flotter
oui voilà on voit y en a vu flotter un
bon voilà on la voit au fond voilà
voyez le petit objet de noir qui en
train de traiter au fond ça n'a pas
retenu
c'est pour montrer qu'ils sont bien en
apesanteur ce que forcément eux ils sont
ils restent attachés à leur siège pour
le moment là on voit le leur leur leur
écran donc rien à voir avec ce qu'ils
avaient une image de la capsule space x
ils ouvrent leurs scaphandres ils ont
donc des gants tactiles qui leur
permettre de manipuler les écrans
savoir ce que c'est c'est un petit jouet
pour enfant quoi s'appelle ces petits
jouets pour enfants flotte la wii qui
ressemble à un petit peu un petit un
petit singe médias ou pas je suis pas
sûr à kiki ouais c'est ça ce serait un
avantage c'est 70 parce que ces lieux
mythiques hitler j'arrive pas à voir ce
que c'est exactement ce qu'est au
premier rang qui flotte au revoir aux
cammazes effectivement c'est très intime
très bon jusque là on pourra voir si
vous savez flotte est sur la droite donc
on voit toujours la capsule tu es en
train de danser douaniers qui va rentrer
sur terre où le temps d'un combat
intense qui va revenir sur terre et ce
qu'on veut dans le temps de le voir
durant sociale le deuxième étage
le président on aurait dû le voir mais
dans le jeu j'ai l'impression que pour
moi il y aurait déjà dû à un doigt il
doit rentrer je vais jamais mon anti
sèches sur steve irwin à 58
donc il a déjà dû revenir à et on n'a
pas vu du coup parce que non mais
peut-être mauvais style peut-être qui
sait s'est pas passé comme prévu celle
que vit c'est raté je ne sais pas
exactement c'est vrai qu'on est passé
sur le va se renseigner on va voir je
pense que pendant plusieurs commentaires
qui nous parle de fair use de montage
notamment celui de romain qui me dit
qu'ils nous dînons par hommage et
oubliez le commentaire d'internaute
c'est complètement faux etc qu'est ce
qu'on dit aux gens qui affirment que
c'est complètement faux tristan c'était
complètement faux il ré manière de faire
vachement plus je lis quoi vivait
interstellar et cetera
c'est vrai ne serait-ce même que first
c'était faire semaine je crois le le
film sur sur armstrong
voilà on aurait bon pour faire des
images incroyables on se contenterait
pas sa part est tenu par elle d'une
petite caméra fixe comme ça oui mais
après on pourrait toujours eu voilà le
jeu pêche nature majestueuse quoi pour
la terre comme ça la courbure de la
terre c'est quand même assez incroyable
après qu'est ce qu'on peut dire aux gens
c'est comme les gens qui pensent que la
terre et la terre est plate
ce qu'on regarde au télescope voilà pour
un télescope c'était d'anti vous voyez
jupiter vous voyez mars vous voyez
saturn voilà elles sont rondes c'est
déboule donc la terre pour être la seule
à être plate est entouré de deux
planètes ronde
pourquoi pas mais ce sera un peu
étonnant il ya plein comme plein d'
indices qui nous montrent que c'est réel
la station spatiale par exemple vous
pouvez la voir passer au dessus de votre
tête
c'est un point lumineux c'est très
prévisible il ya des applis qui vous
prédisez exactement à quel moment elle
va pas c'est pareil pour les satellites
ont conduit des points lumineux dans le
ciel qui bouge les parts du temps ce
sont des satellites
donc là il ya quand même pas mal de
choses qui permettent de de se
convaincre que c'est réel mois après
j'ai vu des décollages de fusées en
direct que voilà on voit bien on voit
bien la fusée suivre la courbure de la
terre par exemple on a un truc qu'elle
retombe à partir d'un certain
moment en fait elle elle retombe pas en
fait qu'elle gagne toujours en altitude
mais elle passe de l'autre côté donc
elle a beau grimper en altitude par
rapport aux points au dessus duquel elle
donne l'impression de tomber c'est assez
c'est assez impressionnant alors vous
voyez les tristes on va essayer voir
chaque lundi de la nasa sur ce plein
écran à cette réalisation d'euros dans
les glaces on va parler un petit peu de
lits et cessent maintenant puisque le
décollage a eu lieu
on va passer sur des questions dans la
dernière demi heure qui nous reste
concernant la station spatiale
internationale avec cette question de
sébastien desnoyers dents sur le chat
youtube qu'on salue qui nous dit bonjour
bonjour ça va se faire quelle est la
mission majeure de cette expédition dans
l'espace est ce qu'on peut redire on a
un petit peu évoqué au début ce que vont
faire
thomas pesquet et les autres dans la
station spatiale internationale qui nous
rejoindre maintenant dont un peu plus de
22h alors ce que font les astronautes
globalement c'est des expériences
scientifiques de physiologie de physique
ex terrasse qui occupe la majeure partie
de leur temps à huit à dix heures par
jour
donc c'est l'espèce de laborantin ils y
ont fait des expériences ça faut le dire
c'est des scientifiques alors c'est des
laborantins lui sourit l information
scientifique mais voilà ils manipulent
des expériences dont ils connaissent pas
forcément précisément
le connaissent pas intérêt ils
connaissent et ce qu'on leur demande
d'être le protocole pour pouvoir prendre
des mesures magny faire une manipulation
tout ce qu'on peut pas faire en fait
depuis le sol et donc des espaces en
orbite pour voir comment se comporte
certaines choses sans la gravité voilà
par exemple l'espérance de manipulation
des protéines ou alain sans gravité
elles ont moins tendance à s'écraser sur
elle même donc ça présente certains
intérêts bois ya pas mal de en gros tout
ce qu'on peut imaginer comme expérience
on dirait à mais qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si est pas la gravité
d'ailleurs voilà l'entraînement thomas
pesquet voilà dans l'eau pour simuler la
gravité voilà et ça ça n'entraîne pas
les deux cas sont donc à la santé vous
savez partie justement
donc s'il ya cet art il a appris une
partie de maintenance qui et faire en
sorte que ce laboratoire volant qui a
maintenant plus de 20 ans ben voilà
continuer à fonctionner correctement
et là il ya une des missions
particulières qui vont être de 2,2
rajouter de nouveaux panneaux solaires
parce que les panneaux solaires qui sont
là depuis 20 ans se dégradent petit à
petit ce qui était prévu et donc oui il
ya de moins en moins d'électricité à
bord de la station et d'ailleurs combien
de temps reste à vivre les ss c'est une
question dans le chat de positif let's
have ça les les pays ont décidé de
prolonger sa vie jusqu'à au moins 2020 4
et après il ya des plans pour en faire
une espèce de 2,2 il devrait y avoir du
tourisme d'abord pour essayer de
financer peut-être justement son
maintien tout ça n'est pas encore
forcément tout à fait graver dans le
marbre extrêmement clair mais il y aura
a priori un peu de tourisme à bord
passer une ou deux semaines
etc elle sera ensuite probablement peu à
peu abandonné il faudra désormais it et
donc voilà faut des plans pour justement
l'art du temps bien sûr pour pas l'avoir
dit pas n'importe comment il fallait
faire en sorte qu'elles qu'elles se des
index que c'est quand même un gros
morceau est alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
tristan comme études pour aller dans
l'espace et d'une question de caroline
stevens sur le chaton a vu
l'entraînement ou thomas pesquet ouais
mais bon qu'est ce qu'il a fait alors
faut savoir qu'en ce moment justement il
ya l'agencé spatiale européenne recrute
donc si vraiment vous voulez devenir
astronaute c'est le moment résine et
puis il ya plusieurs très jeune viewer
qui nous qui nous suivent alors c'est ce
débat de cinq ans six ans tout al'air 5
6 ans et ce sera trop tôt c'est pas
encore il faut avoir un bac + 5
dans une matière scientifique
ça me ferait tout ce qui est pour le
seul prérequis
après j'ai dû faire une condition
physique aussi par m
ouais mais pas nécessairement il
enfin oui il ya des examens de santé qui
seront faits mais c'est pas là dessus
que porte la sélection au tout début
elle est ouverte d'ailleurs pour la
première fois aux personnes qu'ils sont
alors amputé je crois en dessous du
genou d'une jambe
elle est ouverte aux personnes de petite
taille j'oublie j'oubliais j'oublie un
handicap mais voilà donc il n'y a pas
d'accord il n'y a pas de big ou enfin
voilà on il n'y a pas de contraintes sur
le lève l'a vu par exemple que c'est pas
comme les pilotes de chasse
après ben voilà il faut avant certains
pilotes de chasse ont fait des missions
spéciales
après ces décès reste il ya luca
parmitano notamment en italie l'italien
qui est un ancien pilote de chasse
thomas puisqu'il lui un pilote de ligne
c'était le premier à ce mode pilote de
ligne et donc voilà bah allez voir sur
le site de lézat de l'agencé spatiale
européenne ayant fait campagne
astronautes prérequis il ya toute une
documentation vous pouvez vous inscrire
thomas pesquet et que tu me dire que la
partie la plus difficile avait été de
faire son dossier de postuler que après
après on suit les épreuves et des
épreuves
voilà pour regarder votre votre capacité
à résister au stress votre votre logique
voilà c'est un peu comme et s2 cuit une
certaine façon et il va ya beaucoup
beaucoup de prétendants peu d'élus donc
c'est pas évident mais il n'y a pas de
prérequis nom particulier à voir
or or une très grande motivation
un petit message à revendre en l'espèce
à la réalisation si on a enregistré les
images du décollage en valais on va les
repasser dès que dès que vous les avez
en région les recrues mantra avec avec
plaisir en attendant on continue à
prendre vos questions et vos
commentaires sur l'île c'est ce que
thomas pesquet et le reste de l'équipage
vont rejoindre ici 22 heures maintenant
un voyage qui va durer 23 heures puis
cette question pardon de célina qui nous
dit peut-on imaginer un jour une station
spatiale permanente de très grande
envergure comme dans les films de
science fiction
une sorte de
de l'espace est ce que c'est ça un
projet comme celui-ci qui pourrait
remplacer l'actuel iss est ce que c'est
envisageable
je sais pas de très grande envergure
comme ça je l'imaginé pas pour l'instant
avec une dimension qui s y laisser sa
ferme terrain de football à peu près
américain en envergure pas en volume
habitable en volume habitable c'est la
carlingue d'un
d'un avion alors je suis plus c'est un
trip le 7 mars après ça ou un airbus
a330 droit c'est donc un avion au long
cours d'un avion long-courrier un moyen
un moyen-courrier je crois c'est la
carlingue d'un moyen-courrier ça le
volume habitable de l'iace s il ya six à
sept personnes qui vivent ou qui vivent
dedans
et voilà donc quelque chose de beaucoup
plus gros je sais pas pourquoi pas
taillé une très bonne série que je vous
conseille sur le genre de questions sur
justement comment pour économiser le
système solaire qui s'appelle the
expense et qui montre bien les enjeux
des ressources voilà où est ce qu'on
trouve l'eau est ce qu'on pourrait dans
la ceinture d'astéroïdes d'un sur mars
la lune etc
c'est pas mal fait et donc voilà on peut
imaginer il faudrait imaginer une espèce
de deux vaisseaux qui tournent sur
eux-mêmes comme une toupie pour créer un
peu de gravité
voilà vivre sans gravité s'est quand
même pas très bon pour le corps humain
donc j'ai très très longtemps sans
gravité ça ça paraît difficile et
combien de mètres besoin l'affût de la
fusée question voilà demander à vous
demandez rien qu'une seule personne qui
a réussi à que les tristes or est pour
l'instant sur ce sur ce chat question de
tiana napuka sur youtube qu'on salue kg
devant actuellement combien types de
personnes à bord de l'iss est on va y
répondre juste après mais d'abord rendre
sbs nous à retrouver les images
décollage
je propose pour les retardataires
peut-être qu'on est con il revoit
ensemble c'est quand même les images
magnifiques renan renom étaient en train
de lancer ces images voilà landais sur
le sur le replay les images de la nasa
on est quelques secondes avant le
décollage
on va le vivre ensemble j'ai vu clair
que plusieurs personnes étaient
enthousiastes
[Musique]
évidemment qu'il ya des spécialistes
restants pour le reste et spectacle il
fallait exclure non vraiment je pense
pas
et c'est pas que ça entre en ligne de
compte dans pour la nasa ya tellement de
paramètres
en fait ils entrent en compte or dit
haut et sous le sens pas je pense
vraiment pas que ça joue il faut savoir
clairement à la caméra c'est moins
attention quand on est en vrai en vrai
c'est vraiment le soleil qui se lève en
pleine nuit le ciel devient bleu face et
je vois comme en plein jour
ah oui c'est quelques secondes du
décollage pour toi comme en plein jour à
1 12 secondes c'est vraiment le soleil
qui se lève les yeux qui se met à
chanter l'herbe qui le redevient verte
voilà c'est on a du mal à se représenter
à la caméra forcément c'est tellement
brillant qu'en fait il ya il ya
forcément un film et une réduction à
luminosité quoi pour va cramer le
capteur ou par ou même pour pour pas que
ce soit juste un boule blanche blanche
et qu'on ne voit rien donc on a on n'a
pas ce sera un peu moins content
la poussée est extrêmement violente au
décollage j'ai pas je fais exactement
tête
de l'ordre de 900 de 100 kg à peu près
ça ça pousse pas mal quoi et donc pour
revenir à la question posée juste avant
de revoir ces images
combien de personnes actuellement dans
le temps dit s il y en a sept en ce
moment donc avec les contes et légendes
voilà les quatre nouveaux arrivants qui
vont être onze pendant quelques jours
aux abords des seize ça commence à
beaucoup à faire un peu pas mal
traditionnellement c'est l'héritage de 6
là avec le jugement crew dragonne qui a
quatre passagers à bord va pour
optimiser cet équipage de 7,3 qu'il est
dans un soyouz et 4 qui vit dans une
croûte dragonne et puis et puis qui se
relaient comme ça et donc là les quatre
qui étaient montés que la croûte
dragonne lacrouts 1 vont redescendre le
28 avril
question de jordan ayew dans le chat qui
nous dit monfils
adam qu'on salue veut savoir il veut
savoir tristan est ce que les
astronautes vont sortir dans l'espace
une fois dans les ss alors la réponse à
cette question est oui
il sort très régulièrement alors on la
sait avec forcément le décollage de
thomas pesquet la france braque ses yeux
sur les ss et donc on repart on est
beaucoup parlé ya cinq ans mais entre
temps voilà il ya deux équipages il ya
quatre équipes 1 il ya à dire 12
astronautes chaque année qui partent
vers les 16 qui se relaient la station
habitée en permanence depuis cinq ans
j'ai eu des relais et c est à peu près à
chaque à chaque mission d'astronautes il
ya des sorties extravéhiculaires qui
sont prévus donc des sorties en
scaphandre dans l'espace thomas pesquet
en effet deux lors de sa première
mission
là il y en a 4 a priori qui sont
programmées pendant
pendant la durée de sa mission il
pourrait faire les 4 il s'est en tout
cas entraîné en ce sens notamment avec
son collègue japonais et en particulier
pour changer les pour mettre de nouveaux
panneaux solaires de dérouler des
panneaux solaires souples pour essayer
de 2,2 réhaussé de la puissance
électrique fournie par la station qui
est qu'ils baissent avec la dégradation
des panneaux solaires historique et donc
thomas pasquier a de grandes chances ma
connaissance de de faire quelques unes
de ses sorties il est fait des sorties
très réussis lors de ces dernières
missions il avait bluffé ses
instructeurs et les légendes la nasa et
donc du coup il ya de très fortes
chances pour qu'il soit là encore choisi
pour faire une cité u vml ont pas été
officiellement programmée donc je ne
sais pas encore quel jour elles auront
lieu qui ira combien de temps ça dure en
général environ six heures par sortie
c'est très physique parce que là le
scaphandre dépressurisé donc ils sont en
apesanteur mais en fait pour bouger le
scaf pendant qu'elles y sont c'est très
compliqué c'est très très dur ils ont
l'intention de thomas pasquet fils d
l'image disent un peu comme faire de
l'escaladé avec une armure voilà ça n'a
une idée c'est très très physique très
assez épuisant et la botte de
maltraitance et que la sortie dans
l'espace quand elle aura lieu
on la suivra également en direct sur
figaro live donc bien évidemment suivra
pas les six heures on suivra peut-être
pas les six heures mais on suivra quand
même quelques heures mais on l'avait
déjà fait en 2016 2017 on avait suivi en
direct les ait sortis dans l'espace si
vous n'avez jamais vu c'est assez
intéressant parce que c'est vraiment des
ouvriers l'espace
ils vont avec leur petite personne leur
fille outils elles réparer la station de
l'extérieur c'est assez chouette à voir
donc soyez là bien évidemment on mettra
des alertes sur youtube et sur le site
ce n'est pas à vous abonner d'ailleurs
la chaîne youtube pour ne pas rater
c'est c'est prochain live qu'on fera
avec vous toujours avec tristan
peut-être avec cyril à ma collègue
serait mon collègue tristan c'est le fnc
et vous
super5 qui est selon les rebelles que
personne n'a jamais réussi à coller un
chat
peut-être que ce sera le village sera
avec nous en direct
allez on prend encore quelques unes de
vos questions ou de vos commentaires
envoyés derrière nous le live delà de la
nasa s'est terminée il passe maintenant
des images d'archivés mais nous on est
bien avec vos locaux continuent à rester
un petit peu et vous avez l'air bien
avec nous aussi ça nous fait plaisir
puisque vous continuez à nous laisser
vos vos questions et vos commentaires
notamment cette question de luca qui
nous dit ps est situé où précisément à
quelle altitude
elle est séduite s 400 km d'altitude
sa vitesse exacte je les ai pas en tête
et du coup voilà les quatre cinquièmes
être c'est pas très loin finalement
c'est moins loin que lyon de paris
c'est juste parce que c'est très très
loin mais en fait non tout proche c'est
pour ça qu'on a droit depuis la terre
d'ailleurs c'est difficile d'accès c'est
pas loin
matt bell cac ne demande salut salut
maths je voulais savoir si les ss
étaient parfois sans équipage ou est-ce
qu'il ya toujours quelqu'un à
l'intérieur
non est-ce que parfois il n'y a personne
dans les ss je suis parfois elle tourne
tout seul
non non elle est habitée en permanence
depuis plus de 20 ans
elle a failli
elle a failli être abandonné eu des
craintes y avait une histoire de deux
vaisseaux soyouz percée etc a eu d il ya
eu des petites ya eu des retards en fait
90 des retards il ya eu l'accident c'est
de la soul use est plus qu à seignosse
pour emmener des gens à bord il fallait
résoudre le problème qui avait eu sur le
lanceur avant de pouvoir envisager un
nouveau lancement il a été voilà c'est
passé pas loin et ils ont prolongé des
missions d'astronautes etc mais
finalement les restes et elle est restée
habité en permanence c'est toujours le
cas et je me suis trompé tout à l'heure
un apparemment elle devait revenir sur
une barge le premier tech devait revenir
sur une barge
j'en profite pour dire à rendre les
baisses voilà qui repasse les images du
décollage dans l'espèce le réalisateur
que si on a également des images du
direct ci peut me confirmer que le live
nasa et bien terminée qu'on a plus de
plus aucune image sinon sera d image de
la capsule
n'hésitons pas d aller passer derrière
pour prendre encore allé cinq minutes
les dernières les dernières questions et
les commentaires tienne christian pour
vos tristan le pilote mois comme doivent
bientôt journaliste spécialiste de
l'espace on parle beaucoup des
astronautes mais comment devient tristan
la question ça vaut pas grand chose il
ya plein de manières différentes j'irai
il ya on peut faire une école de
journalisme
ensuite essayez d'aller dans des médias
spécialisés des médias généralistes et
puis petit à petit voilà ce que j'ai
fait mais il ya aussi des passionnés qui
prennent la plume et qui créent leurs
blogs leurs médias vous pour créer votre
chaîne youtube et vous spécialiser comme
ça je dirais qu'il ya pas il faut être
passionné
[Musique]
voilà et après il n'y a pas de ya pas de
règles particulières pour après rentrant
les traditionnels bains faire des stages
pour voir ça vous plaît n'hésitez pas si
vous avez vous êtes jeune vous voulez
faire d'autres achats de fin de
troisième au figaro on accueille très
volontiers des des gens pour qu'ils
voient la réalité du métier comment ça
marche
et ensuite il n'y a pas de règle
particulière à faire des prêts
journaliste globalement faire des études
un bac plus trois équipes de la chose
qui vous intéresse le plus c'est ensuite
tenter les concours d'écoles de
journalisme pour y rentrer ou alors
commencer directement en faisant des
stages petit à petit en écrivant en
faisant des piges en s'intéressant à un
travailleur beaucoup quand il faut dire
font un vrai intérêt pour son sujet
après je pensais comme beaucoup de
choses il n'y a pas de haut revient dans
l'espace tristan avec cette question
simple d'arrêt à prod complétée par
celle de sévery dans le chatt youtube
tout simplement à quoi sert le ss et
séverine dit si les ss n'existait plus
qu'est ce qu'on ferait en gros
est-ce qu'on enverrait encore des
diffusé à ce rôle dans l'espace s'il n'y
avait plus les ss puisqu'on va plus sur
la lune on va pas encore sur mars
seul moment où on envoie des astronautes
dans l'espace c'est pour aller dans les
ss s'il n'était plus là est ce que ce
serait un endroit problème abonnement
sera pas du tout un problème est
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est la raison
même d'être de l'iace sc2 d'envoyer des
astronautes faut forcément les agences
spatiales bon c'est le jeu et elle
présente la liesse aces commettant un
laboratoire en orbite qui permet de
faire des choses qu'on peut faire sur
terre c'est à moi c'est à moitié vrai
et qu'il faut envoyer des astronautes la
oprah les expériences et pour la faire
fonctionner mais je pense qu'il faudra
les faisant un peu de manière la manière
inverse
en fait on a créé l' iss pour envoyer
des astronautes et pas l'inversé on va
pas des astronautes pour maintenir l'
iss en vie et quand il ya ce ne sera
plus là parce que finalement ça fait 20
ans a coûté très cher ça a permis
d'entretenir toutes les technologies
nécessaires de la dorcas ya pas de 10
est celle ci n'aurait pas refait des
capsules par exemple mais l'étape
d'après c'est d'aller faire un peu la
même chose en orbite lunaire donc plus
loin et c'est une nouvelle étape dans
l'exploration du système solaire
et là ce sera donc une station en orbite
autour de la lune et l'idée sera de
faire des allers retours entre cette
station et le sol lunaire pour
éventuellement établir une base sur la
lune et après la même manière que pôle
iss on a inventé une utilité l iss on
inventera une utilité à une base lunaire
ça pourra être pour faire de
l'astronomie par exemple sur la face
cachée de la lune
voilà c'est intéressant si la paille a
plus la terre qui nous qui nous
dérangent et sa lumière on peut faire de
la radioastronomie de pression on
inventera je pense d'eux des choses à
faire et de la science à faire sur la
sur la lune et peut-être que les agences
spatiales justifieront le fait qu'on
fait une base lunaire pour faire de la
science alors que je pense qu'on fera de
la science surtout pour faire de
l'exploration spatiale en soi et c'est
une très bonne chose que ce soit comme
ça je pense que les gens ont envie de
rêver la position de l'ancien directeur
spatiale de directeur de l'agencé
spatiale européenne je trouvais été très
bien il avait un grand projet de village
lunaire et et quand lui demander à quoi
ça sert il vous répondez que ça en soit
c'était ça le but c'était de faire un
village une aire et qui avait pas besoin
que ça serve à quelque chose
voilà à quoi ça sert de faire un village
tout court ce à quoi ça sert d'aller
faire une expédition au pôle sud au pôle
nord on arrive toujours à trouver un
intérêt à prendre un thermomètre avec
soi faire un peu de science à aller à
dire que ben voilà on va aller explorer
un fond marin prendre des photos faire
tout ce qu'on veut mais au final c'est
l'exploration pour l'exploration je
pense que pour la lune comme pour mars
ce sera la même chose sera l'exploration
pour l'exploration à l'une des toutes
dernières questions à peu technique
avant de terminer seul à mes questions
de frédéric sautier qui veulent vendre
kelleher gones sont utilisés est ce que
ce sont les mêmes à tous les étages de
la fusée
alors déjà faut définir ce que c'est
qu'un d'ergols pour tous alors les
ergols c'est le carburant le carburant
de la fusée
aux dires de l'essence bon c'est en
l'occurrence dire il ya du kérosène il
ya aussi de l'oxygène liquide
pour le premier étage et deuxième étages
c'est juste de l'oxygène liquide
voilà après ça dépend des fusées voit la
question de side à tort car dans le chat
qu'on salue est-ce que astronautes c'est
bien payé et si oui combien c'est pas
mal payés c'est pas mal payés mais si
vous voulez gagner de l'argent il ya des
métiers mieux rémunérés alors il ya des
grilles dit oui devant internet de
mémoire comme ça c'est entre cinq et
huit mille euros après ça dépend du
grath dépend du temps qu'on a passé
encore des astronautes
il ya une grille c'est vraiment alors
cessé c'est net d'impôts parce que
l'agencé spatiale européenne
on n'est pas soumis à l'impôt sur le
revenu contre comme quand on travaille
pour pour l'europe pour l'union
européenne et ses cd agence exact exact
voilà donc donc cesser ses confortables
c'est un bon salaire et voilà c'est
passé pâle par rapport au niveau de
compétence heureux qui l'entraînement et
le travail que ça peut représenter
l'investissement voilà ça ne paraît pas
et ça ne paraît pas excessif
allez on va terminer ce live sur cette
question de tiana que le monde bonjour
silva tristan bonjour à vous après votre
live où peut-on continuer assure le
lancement de la mission alpha et quand
arrivera l'équipage à bord de l' iss
donc on peut déjà on peut continuer à
les suivre sur le site du figaro puisque
tristan après la après cela il va aller
écrire les articles
on va je l'imaginais annoncé aussi au
moment le moment où ils arriveront à un
ss vous imagine le suivre sur le site de
la nasa directement pendant qu'elle est
par contre oui soucier de la nasa sur le
site youtube la nasa en direct on peut
suivre également effectivement sur le
site du figaro l'arrivée est prévue
demain matin donc vers 11 heures mettant
entre 10 heures et entre eux entre 10
heures du matin et midi vous aurez
l'arrivée des astronautes dans la
station spatiale où on l'aura en vidéo
enfin internationale quand je dis nous
le figaro finir en live vous pouvez la
retrouver sur le site les images de
l'arrivée des exactement là il va y
avoir un temps un peu creux aller aux
médias les 20 prochaines heures il va
pas se passer grand chose je pense pas
que la nasa suivra en direct les 23
heures de vol ce même sûr que non ils
vont couper leur live probablement assez
rapidement on n'a pas tenu à ma
connaissance n'a pas une nouvelle du
premier étage qui dit revenir sur une
barge flottante
donc je ne sais pas exactement pour
quelles raisons on va vérifier ça voilà
tu as des problèmes de communication sic
la barre peut-être qu'il ya un accident
on appelle une nouvelle fois c'est la
tambouille interne de space x la nasa
elle n'a pas la main là dessus cesser
les opérations de space x qui font un
peu ce qu'ils veulent
et voilà merci beaucoup tristan merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis dans le tchat
sur la page de une du figaro.fr et sur
la chaîne youtube du fijo n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à la chaîne youtube du
figaro puisque comme je le disais nous
allons
faire d'autres live comme celui ci
notamment pour la prochaine sortie dans
l'espace de thomas pesquet vous pourrez
également retrouver les vod c'est à dire
les vidéos enregistrées de notamment de
l'arrivée de la capsule à l iss et son
accrochage à allier cesse et pour les
retardataires qui demandent où est ce
qu'on peut revoir le décollage je les
ratés et c est justement on va terminer
ce live donc foutent rien qu'à regarder
la vod qui va apparaître tout de suite
sur la chaîne youtube pour le revoir
dont on vous dit à très bientôt
merci beaucoup tristante merci beaucoup
et bonne fin de journée sur le figaro
sur figaro live vous ne ratez pas tout à
leur prochaine mission son figaro light
à 17 heures et ce sera le débat point de
vue avec anne emmanuelle isaac voile
après midi à tous et à très vite pour la
prochaine sortie dans l'espace de thomas
pesquet évidemment on vous tient au
courant
au revoir ciao
[Musique]
fort
non
m